en me baladant dans notre belle région
je croise souvent sur le bord des routes
de magnifiques châteaux privés donc je
rêve de pousser le portail depuis des
années eh bien figurez vous que c'est
possible
désormais grâce à une nouvelle
application château de bourgogne et de
franche-comté et on commence par le
château de françoise akis sur un coup de
coeur il ya 20 ans il est construit sur
le modèle du petit trianon
elle en a fait des chambres d'hôtes mais
souhaite aujourd'hui le partager avec un
plus grand nombre de visites en finale
bonjour bienvenue revue merci après ce
matin là en pleine discussion avec
patricia paula herth la propriétaire du
château de couches à l'origine du projet
françoise affine les détails afin
d'intégrer le cercle de la soixantaine
de château qui composent l'association
fait dans des châteaux qu'il soit venu
modèle rick avant tout avec une histoire
une belle architecture dgr fichier est
fier qu'il soit vraiment très mal
invisible
alors on s'enlève le petit pas faire des
servantes à l'époque un agrès 5 17
maintenant nous fêtions justine et le
jardin à l'intervention aller devant la
chambre et la comtesse en lui 500 go non
c'est la chambre et après de la chambre
de la comtesse dons que vous avez les
alcools et deux de chaque côté vous avez
des petites portes
elle était destinée aux fervents qui
ferait leur des placards non ce ne sont
pas des placards vous voyez ça
correspondait avec le le grand couloir
et les servantes apporter ce petit
déjeuner malin à monsieur voilà à taizé
petit endroit un cas chez les enfants
mais bien il ya la vie c'est la vie de
château
alors votre grand salon on appelle ça le
salon boiseries en général y ait cinq
salons pendant les châteaux des
huitièmes voilà ce salon avant et c'est
par ici le blanc et or et les anciens
propriétaires l'ont des caps et voilà or
ils m'ont dit en laissant le château
maintenant vous mettrez 25 kg de 2,6
répu faites le moi j'aime j'aime les
grands espaces j'aime la lumière je
pourrais pas être dans un château féodal
franchement c'est tout noir et qui a pas
d'ouverture
pervez avec le soleil c'est à l'aiea
prend mal à combattre sans merci pour la
libye et ban prochain changement de
département mais aussi d'époque
le château de jr en haute saône est une
ancienne place forte du xiiie siècle
transformé jusqu'au 18e propriété de
l'archevêché de besançon pendant plus de
sept fois en 34 archevêques qui sont
supprimés aujourd'hui d'un jour est un
propriétaire
pourquoi ohlala j'ai simplement le
gardien revanche certains vols
connaissent nerfs ou pratiquement 8
depuis 68 27 18
elle ne s'est pas élargie toujours je
vous le montre janot nous nous amener
directement dans la chambre du roy la
chambre du créateur du château le
cardinal de choses un nouveau prêt
regardez sol ici c'est pas beau ça n
allait essayer vraiment rideau remercie
comme ça c'était pas beau ça fiche soit
quand il faisait frais des titres des
teintures nous ont été fournies par
chercher besançon ils sont vraiment du
xviiie la plus belle pièce la voici
approchant de la commande chinoise du
cardinal de fleury beaupré à la
révolution pouliguen château était un
public jeune amant y avait plus rien et
comme un trou d inventaire très précis
l'un c'est brit air donc pu reconstruire
l'intégralité de l'interview il est
content de voir que ce château quand
même les jeunes occupant pendant cinq
pièces on change carrément n'est pas
carrément brantôme au xvième siècle avec
le cardinal clause de la baume sacré
chasseurs d'ailleurs ça se voit la suit
pas c'est que ça d'ailleurs on le voit
sur l'emblème il ya vingt-deux viêt
les seniors ii le seigneur jean avec 22
par deux chefs là restait 2 pour les
habitants de gilles sunu déprimante de
l'orgueil à la regarder la belle petite
porte
sa cave secrète de l'archevêque génère
une très grande région viticole
tout ça n'est pas résident l'oreille
d'un sourd javier guillaume quête un
vigneron numérique a donc décidé du jour
résume propriétaire au de recréer le 22
mars et des architectes du 16e siècle
et voilà je vous présentais le secret du
château de j
le sort a lieu
6 à 6 - toulouse comme à l'époque comme
à l'époque exact on parle de même ville
et du comté les noirs on a eu du coup
des lois et des amoureux de leur château
comme jeannot et françoise il y en a ou
quatre points de la région
vous pourrez les retrouver tout l'été
grâce à ce nouveau guide m